[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn here if you appreciate my
content you can help out tremendously by
clicking the like button
so that the youtube algorithm recognizes
when i upload videos
so in the midst of the information that
the dune movie is being postponed
several weeks and this is the like third
postponement
apple tv has decided to release the
second
foundation trailer now as some of you
guys may know
i was really excited about the first
trailer that they came out with because
i'm a huge fan
of the foundation books by isaac asimov
they are classic science fiction books
and they laid the groundwork
for the idea of the galactic empire that
is something that asimov
invented with his creation of the
foundation series
and he also expanded upon it in his
galaxy series and also the robot
series but foundation is really the
central core of where that all started
so i was very excited to see that it was
being adapted
and it was being adapted with a budget
now we got the first trailer and it
really didn't show us
exactly what we would be seeing in this
first
season i guess and the reason that's
important is because if you've read the
foundation series
then you know that it doesn't really
stay in the same time
for very long like each section is
skipping decades and decades into the
future because it's about
the rise and fall of a galactic
civilization
and really foundation is not the first
series that you think
of when you think of what could be being
adapted as far as classic science
fiction foundation is not on the list
because
it doesn't seem like something that's
very adaptable so
and the first trailer didn't give us
really a clear idea of what exactly
which parts of the book they're adapting
and what they were embellishing
but now that the second trailer has come
out we get a clear picture of the things
that are being embellished and added to
the story
as well as things that they are taking
from the story and expanding upon
so basically from the look of the
trailer it looks as though
this first season of the foundation
series at least
is going to be about the fall of trantor
itself which is something that's not
actually depicted
in the book so you have the beginning
opening
we have gail dornick and you have harry
selden uh on the planet trantor and
they're petitioning the emperor and tel
and to start the foundation because they
know through
mathematical cycle history that the
empire is headed towards a decline and
essentially a crash and harry selden has
a plan to save it so
it gets pretty complicated from there
but essentially the book
kind of ends and that first section with
harry selden
being allowed to make the foundation
which is basically
explained to the emperor as a place
where people will go
to write down everything in the universe
ever like the history of the entire
universe the encyclopedia galactica
so that they will be able to keep all
the information in the universe and that
will be the way of maintaining the
history of humanity and ensuring the
survival of the empire essentially but
that's not harry's actual plan his plan
his
real plan is actually way more
complicated and we're not going to get
into that but that's the essential
gist of like what he's setting up for
the emperor
so looking at this show it is
definitely taking some liberties with
the story
it is definitely borrowing in my opinion
from the work of frank herbert
in several ways uh i'm getting some
tylaxu vibes with the genetic
engineering that seems to be a part of
the show that's not in the books
um and i'm also getting a dune vibe with
this whole family structure that they're
setting up with the
leader of the empire now because that's
not really a thing
in the the original foundation book
it we don't really we don't see the
emperor's family it's not about them
it's not about the characters so it
seems here that they're
pulling oh i want i don't mean to scare
you but they're pulling kind of a game
of thrones thing where they're like
they're going to focus on different
groups of people and we're going to
center the story around the time in
which trantor
fell now i've already done a breakdown
of the
canonical lore involving the follow
trantor and you can check out that video
it should pop up here but
i have to say as far as like things that
are written
as far as like narratively involving
what happened during that time there is
not much from isaac asimov
so i imagine that this show will be it's
it's leaning a lot on these
writers to write what happened during
the time
which we pretty much expect it because
this story like to adapt it you have to
make some pretty significant changes to
like the flow of the story and you're
gonna have to add things
to beef up certain sections that's
that's the only way really that you're
gonna get like audiences to connect with
it in
tv show form so i understand why they're
making
some of these changes and i also
understand from like
a business standpoint why are there
taking some beats for from dune
they know that dune kind of has like
this cold following
like there's never been a foundation
movie made before there's
in the way that doom doesn't have the
same cultural
influence that something like star wars
has even though dune is older and was
something that's
an influence on star wars foundation
does not have the influence that dune
has even though foundation is something
that's older and was an influence on
dune
so so honestly i understand why they're
taking some of those beats from doom and
i'm not really mad about it i knew this
the foundation book would have to be
embellished to be adapted
and they would have to add some things
and at least they're adding some cool
things that i actually
enjoy conceptually anyway now visually
the show looks great the cgi looks
really good the costumes are impressive
i think
just the whole general aesthetic of it
is beautiful and i really enjoyed the
sound design of the trailer as well
i hope that the show has a similar sound
design now i have seen a couple of shows
on apple tv who is the production
company behind
this tv show or miniseries or whatever
it's going to be i think it's a
i don't know how many episodes exactly
it'll be so i have seen a few apple tv
things some of them
have been not so great and others have
been
pretty good uh for instance c i thought
had
some pretty high production values so
that is the standard being set then i
think
as far as production quality goes this
show is pretty set
now as far as like the writing of the
show will it be good
i have no idea i just have to see it i
have no idea if the writing is good or
not
but if they follow in the basic tenets
and ideas that
asimov put forth in the foundation books
then i
see no reason why this couldn't be an
enjoyable
experience for fans of the book series
and people that are
not fans of the book series people that
just want to enjoy an interesting sci-fi
story and also as always my hope with
something like this
is that it will be good enough that it
will bring
people to the books right and even if
it's not great it'll still probably
bring people to the books because that
always happens
so as long as this gets people
interested in classic science fiction
and these really cool
ideas then i'm all for it and honestly
i'm just happy to be
alive in a time where i can see azimov's
foundation
and frank herbert's dune being adapted
with
huge budgets and a lot of effort put
into it
and to be adapted by people who seem to
understand the material very well
i mean i know definitely that denny
valenov and his team behind dune
really get dune and what it means and i
hope that the people behind foundation
really understand
what foundation is and what asimov was
trying to say
with the foundation series so as long as
they do that
then i mean it can't hurt can it so
i don't want to make this video too long
thank you guys so much for watching
uh if you haven't seen the foundation
trailer i will leave a link for it in
the description
it is pretty sick um make sure you like
and subscribe for more quinn's ideas and
if you want
more lore on the foundation books
i have plenty of it on my channel you
can check the playlist link to the
foundation videos that i've made in the
description of this video
peace out guys
you